un día muy esperado para los franceses
que vuelven a gozar de un poco más de
libertad después de casi siete meses con
la reapertura no solamente de comercios
esenciales sino también de cafés de
restaurantes y también de sitios
culturales algunos aprovecharon para ir
muy temprano a la función de cine de
ocho de la mañana a otros para regresar
esos viejos hábitos como tomarse un café
antes de comenzar todas las actividades
del día ya a este momento son la hora
del almuerzo ya hay muchas personas que
están llegando a las diferentes terrazas
de restaurantes y cafés hay que saber
que estos establecimientos pueden
recibir público pero con un aforo
limitado y únicamente en terraza es
decir únicamente en exteriores o al
menos por ahora también se espera que
las horas de la tarde-noche con la hora
de la cena pues se también haya bastante
afluencia de público eso sí tendrá que
ser una cena temprano porque el 'toque
de queda' continúa solo que esta vez
comienza a partir de las nueve de la
noche esto a partir de este día
miércoles hay muchas expectativas mucha
expectativa en el país con esta
reapertura que se espera sea sostenida a
largo plazo y también de las reactivas
de la economía todo esto va a la par de
unas cifras mucho mejores por parte de
la epidemia ya que la tasa de incidencia
está por debajo de los 150 casos por
100.000 habitantes en todo el país y que
la campaña de vacunación se ha acelerado
con un poco más de 20 millones de
franceses que ya recibieron al menos la
primera dosis de la vacuna contra el cob
y 19